[Applaus]
sie sind krank und wollen nichts als
leben
sie warten auf ein organ dass ein
verstorbener spendet
ein leben geht zu ende
eines wird verlängert die
organtransplantation ist ein eingriff
der bewegt es geht um ethik glaube
gesetz und moral
um großes glück
ich freue mich darauf wie verrückt jetzt
auf diesen nächsten abschnitt in meinem
leben und bin sehr dankbar dass ich das
alles erleben darf und um ängste was
bedeutet die transplantation für die
empfängerinnen und empfänger wie genau
läuft sie ab mit umzieht 20 nach acht
und die liebe ist sehr schön
[Musik]
wahnsinnig geduld
wie es die lebensqualität nach dem
großen eingriff es geht um warten
[Musik]
hoffnung und vielleicht erlösung
bruno bike start
bruno roman lebt mit einem kunstherz die
akkus trägt er in einer tasche mit sich
seit 2004 leidet er unter herzproblemen
von jahr zu jahr
ging es ihm schlechter vor einem jahr
verschlechterte sich sein
gesundheitszustand rapide im
universitätsspital lausanne bekam er als
überbrückung ein kunstherz auch herz
assistent genannt
[Musik]
jetzt wartet der 41-jährige auf das herz
eines spenders unglaublich oder die
andere heißt aber nicht dass wir haben
dann keine positiv traum bis zur
transplantation braucht sein herz strom
aus der batterie relativ groß und die
tony larussa batterie hat zwölf stunden
und dafür ist der apparat für die nacht
deines kaputten ging hier der leyen zwar
die komplette system mit dem schlaf
fördert genug aber wir merken dass die
gare eben via pc schwer
das würde die brenner oder sollen diese
ging der stadt patras ließ so hat ein
knapp und liebhaber der regel passiert
ohne kunstherz droht der körper
nachhaltig schaden zu nehmen
so dass er den strapazen einer
transplantation irgendwann nicht mehr
standhalten könnte die linke habe fast
meine kraft kommt es ganz blutjungen
lauf zu bringen wozu turbine gegen
konstant glichkeit gerät das blut
automatischen upload roman ist patient
am unispital lausanne einem der sechs
transplantationszentren der schweiz
sein fall gilt nicht als dringlich für
die zuteilung der organe ist die
stiftung swisstransplant verantwortlich
grund stolz vor sich geht creme
priorisierung das heißt er ist regulär
auf der warteliste
es ist klein es komplikationen geht dann
natürlich zentrum bitte dringend rät
beate merk aus einem probleme mit dem
grund stark zulegen bisher durfte
ballack ins kritik entsteht der kann
diese geräte beitragen
für den roman ist situation insofern
natürlich gut wo in der schweiz die
experten sehr gut zu fuß dusche und die
zahl von der dringlichkeit wie viel
frisches im benachbarten ausland mehr
hervor der herztransplantationen so
dringlich sie und zwar hätte sie regulär
und das ist ganz wichtig dass aber genau
die patienten waren kunst hat sie die
chance deutschland berufen zur technik
für sondern kann die warte dauer spielt
nur eine untergeordnete rolle
priorität hat die rettung von
schwerstkranken das heißt dass patienten
auf der warteliste oft erst ein organ
bekommen wenn es ihnen ganz schlecht
geht
bruno roman wartet die gedanken an die
bevorstehende transplantation holen ihn
immer wieder ein
vor allem nachts im schlaf bekomme dank
quasi haben
bis 5
[Musik]
so wie bruno roman sind mehr als 80
weitere herz patientinnen und herz
patienten auf der warteliste
die durchschnittliche wartezeit für eine
herztransplantation beträgt zurzeit rund
neun monate
die zeit steht still
für katja und martin rast die stimmung
ist gedrückt
ihre tochter liegt im operationssaal für
eine lebertransplantation
zwei wochen vorher mehr erlebt einen
normalen alltag aber sie leidet unter
einem extrem seltenen gendefekt zweimal
schon erkrankte sie lebensbedrohlich ein
einfacher infekt wie ein schnupfen kann
jederzeit wieder ein akutes
leberversagen auslösen
der einzige weg zur heilung ist eine
lebertransplantation
maria ist auf der warteliste richtiger
wenn sie auf die super richtige licht
tatsächlich wird miriam nach wenigen
tagen schon aufgeboten
ein helikopter fliegt sie ins
universitätsspital genf ins
schweizerische kinder lieber zentrum
[Musik]
die kinder chirurgin barbara wild habe
versucht mir ja zu beruhigen
aber auch für die eltern sind es schwere
stunden natürlich auch kürzer und essex
reese decken die transplantation beginnt
um 11 uhr am mittag wollte die wohnung
das genfer unispital hat den eltern für
die nächste zeit eine günstige wohnung
zur verfügung gestellt
seit jahren leben die eltern in angst
seit dem ersten zusammenbruch marias in
bulgarien katjas heimat
sie findet keine ruhe und noch eine cd
von maschinen und medikamenten in der
letzten nacht sind sie nach genf gereist
haben und kaum geschlafen jetzt wissen
sie sich ausruhen
sie haben jetzt einen des komischen
beruhigungstablette bestand und
stickstoff stunden 2
aber katar hält es nicht aus sie will
zurück ins spital
barbara wildhaber ist die einzige
chirurgen in der schweiz die kinder
lebern transplantiert
sie arbeitet daran alles für den
späteren austausch von marias lieber
vorzubereiten
genetisch schon in der letzten schweren
krankheitsphase ja hier in genf das war
vor drei jahren damals hatten die ärzte
kaum mehr hoffnung für sie die
erforschung der krankheit steckt noch in
den anfängen
[Musik]
inselspital haupteingang mitarbeiter von
wes transplant bringen ein termin auf
dem sich besucher und patienten im
nationalen organspende register
eintragen können
das register gibt es seit gut einem jahr
bisher haben sich aber nur 70.000
menschen eingetragen
drei davon wurden effektiv organspender
ob dieses terminal etwas daran ändert
weiß heute niemand
matthias aebischer hat schon oft erlebt
dass die angehörigen nicht genau wussten
ob ein verstorbener seine organe spenden
will oder nicht
er muss diese region dem tod
beschäftigen
wir wollen uns zwischen machen
sie verändere sich aus mit blick auf das
werk gemacht dass es die möglichkeit
gibt und das ist gut dass man sich dazu
ist es nicht die angehörigen machen und
in dieser situation ist es einfach
schwierig und für sie haben ja oder nein
medica wünscht sich einen klaren
entscheid zur organspende am besten
schriftlich festgehalten
in einem anderen trakt des inselspitals
ist die chirurgin vanessa bands auf dem
weg zu einem patienten der vor kurzem
transplantiert wurde
rené eckardt hat mehrere wochen reha
hinter sich
es ist
drei monate ist es her seit rené eckardt
eine spender leber bekam weil er die
seltenen blutgruppe b hat wagte er kaum
mehr darauf zu hoffen und konnte sein
glück kaum fassen
[Musik]
nach der transplantation kam renegat an
seine grenzen
fast genau zwei dreimal komplett
geschlossen die visionale tiere wenn die
tour gestartet bin und ich kann mich wie
gefangen gefühlt
natixis stand irgendwie bemerkbar machen
das kommt mir jetzt also eine festung
nachhinein richtig zu bewusstsein oder
vanessa bands wurde mehrmals ans bett
gerufen und stand ihrem patienten breit
wenn es ihm schlecht ging und das sei ja
immer wieder prozent eiweiß ist ich
schwierige steht kriegt eine situation
erkannt dass nicht schlecht
das verbot das ist die vorteile mithilfe
tanz und geht dass man sieht man weiß
dass ich vorübergehend und dass rund
jeder patient und ideen steckt frauen
sind wirklich um gottes man muss also
bindet damit sie sich selber nicht tut
mache und ich lüge dass ich den rest ja
das ist schwierig denn hätte der
transplantation technisch problematisch
das ist natürlich reden ideale
kombination aber es ist realität machen
mit dem bus waren und uns entsprechend
hätte dann ein holpriger verlaufen
der 63 jährige steckt noch immer in der
aufbauphase
er traut seinem körper noch nicht ganz
weg
und auch das führte dazu dass sie sich
anstrengen
das kommt schon viel besser
oder hab ich mal eine reederei würden
wenn du darauf sein
ich habe mich gut bewegt beim 8 8
es macht so viel in kleinen schritten
geht es zurück in den alltag renegat
sieht wieder eine zukunft als
städtereise machen mit der frau steht wo
sie noch nicht gesehen habe
auf dem 10 fährt sind zum beispiel
moskau sankt petersburg aber so wie
berlin sicher was man gemeinsam gern
möchte die skifahrer dann was wir an
gemeinsamen gerne mit sie ist jetzt noch
sehr aktiv im moment natürlich locker
schließen das ist dreh und meter
schießen
und je nachdem ist körperlich
da ist mein schöner machen also schickte
und grüne karte kehrt zurück nach hause
auf der intensivstation des inselspitals
ist eine patientin gestorben
[Musik]
nebenan in einem besprechungsraum wartet
der ehemann in richtung kalkar
sie stürzt und damit auf baumschlager
politik es inhaltlich an und für sich
harmlos jetzt bewusst und ist denn am
erbrochenen erstickt aber so oft
überholt doch jetzt ein herzstillstand
sie hätten könne reanimiert werden aber
steine sind groß sie so dass sie denn
jetzt nach zwei täglich verstorben ist
im inselspital
die ärzte haben mit der familie
gesprochen und es steht fest die frau
ist organspenderin sie wird deshalb
weiterhin beatmet
jetzt geht es darum den hirntod
offiziell festzustellen
die frau ist tief komatös ohne narkose
medikamente ist gut dass man eigentlich
machen willst dass alle hirnstamm reflex
in der loge sind dass das reh funktion
mehr vom historisch mit dem proben
bewiesen dass durch blutig vom himmel
gefallen ist
die ärzte prüfen ob sich das auge der
patientin schließt wenn es mit einem
wattestäbchen berührt wird
matthias nebl drückt auf gewisse
schmerzpunkte keine reaktion
und er testet ob sich der kopf
reflexartig zurück dreht wie das bei
einem schlafenden der fall wäre
mit einem kleinen schlauch wird der
rachen berührt der reflex bleibt auch
hier aus der ablauf der hirntod
diagnostik ist streng geregelt
zwei unabhängige ärzte ein
intensivmediziner und eine neurologin
müssen das prozedere gemeinsam
durchführen
schließlich wird der beatmungs tourbus
eine minute lang entfernt um zu klären
ob die patientin selbstständig atmen
würde
sind wir alle hin den stamm reflex es in
der loge prozent
beide ärzte unterschreiben das protokoll
hier endet ein leben das ist der
todeszeitpunkt
[Musik]
dank der beatmung sieht es aus als würde
die frau einfach schlafen
kritiker der organtransplantation
stellen in frage ob eine hirntote person
wirklich nichts mehr spürt dem
organspender werde ein würdevolles
sterben verwehrt hektische definition
ohne findet dass es legitim ist das mega
das macht es aus alsdorf definierung
fertig schafft für ein organ spannend es
ist unbestritten dass nicht jede
körperzelle dem sie in funktion verloren
hat was was klar ist dass hirnfunktionen
verständlicherweise nicht nur durch blut
10 ist das wo es uns nachts die
patienten wache nehmen
[Musik]
in schock und trauer sehen sich die
angehörigen mit der frage nach einer
organspende konfrontiert
in diesem fall hat sich die familie
dafür entschieden
ich denke dass ich sie schon sehen vom
in der verstorbene frau und will sie dem
medizinischer tiermedizinischen bereich
tätig ist und mir bald also meine
tochter und ich mein gefühl dass mir
sich im sinn von der urlaub meiner frau
entschieden und es hat auch nicht
irgendwer lange überlegt braucht sondern
ich glaube meine ihrem sinn entschieden
[Musik]
mit ihrem entscheid gehört familie werde
zu einer minderheit
nur 40 prozent der angehörigen
entscheiden sich in dieser
ausnahmesituation für eine organspende
[Musik]
zurzeit warten rund 1400 menschen auf
ein spenderorgan
[Musik]
wird du nicht landeplatz vor der
gleichen nacht operation paragliding war
bruno romans leidenschaft bis ihnen das
herz im stich ließ jetzt verfolgt der
die wettkämpfe auf einer ab das ist so
ein wettkampf mit gletschern flügellauf
von salzburg bis nach monaco und quer
durch die quasi wir haben blöde
verfolgen
naja der pilot hat eine andere linie
fahren die flüchten
hier tritt der schweizerisch am laufer
gleitschirmfliegen ist und bleibt für
ihn der traum wird froh sein matura who
flüge frei wie ein vogel
[Musik]
die stanze flüge speziell ja ja
der alltag allerdings holt grüne roman
rasch wieder ein
in plagen finanzielle sorgen abklärungen
bei versicherung und iv ziehen sich hin
der ist aufgegangen bis jetzt habe der
netzhaut die waadt hat monika karsch auf
vorbescheid wies auf das gold hat dank
das sowie hund aber das muss ich nicht
bewusst was immer geschafft was ein im
märz wird das ganze schon wieder gut
die blattkritik der statistik die papier
gemacht herr you ja das ganze jahr
vergangen schrieb ja
am universitätsspital genf hofft katja
rast auf eine nachricht aus dem
operationssaal
nebenan ist die transplantation in
vollem gang
die chorleiterin des kinderzentrums
barbara wildhaber ist zufrieden wir
haben die größe die htg dass man gemeint
haben konzentriert liegt die ärztin
marias kranke leber frei die
spenderleber trifft erst ein wenn alles
bereit ist
aber erst muss ich bis jetzt behauptet
nicht blindlings traurig dass er aus
liebe hass braucht keine produktion
wählen würde wenn sie hier nicht gerne
sieht das stimmt ja auch kurz los
katja mast ist erleichtert obwohl die
eigentliche transplantation noch
bevorsteht
[Musik]
am inselspital laufen die vorbereitungen
für die organentnahme anita rooney ist
eine der organspende koordinatorinnen
der insel
sie leitet den ganzen organentnahme
prozess und steht in ständigem kontakt
mit den hinterbliebenen also im moment
ist die arche für jedes organ und
mitglied des eigentlichen organ ab klar
als es heißt werden als ultra schall
machen um dem computer tomograph von
buch und photonische gemacht worden
rückt die empfänger zentren wollen
sicher sein dass sie für ihre patienten
voll funktionsfähige organe bekommen und
keine krankheit unentdeckt bleibt es
braucht blutuntersuchungen und gewebe
typisierungen um herauszufinden zudem
die organe am besten passen die
wärmeregulierung des hirns funktioniert
nicht mehr
[Musik]
es fällt auf die pflegefachfrau erklärt
jeden schritt obwohl die patientin
verstorben ist
[Musik]
das hat für mich was auch mit
respektvollem betreuen zu tun und sie
ist für mich nach wie vor einfach
menschenseele
absolut wie lange bleibt die seele im
körper gibt es sie überhaupt wird der
sterbeprozess durch die organentnahme
gestört auch wenn medizinisch alles klar
ist für viele bleiben fragen offen
[Musik]
die koordinatorin erfasst alle
medizinischen daten in einem system auf
das auch die transplantation spitäler
zugriff haben dann wird swiss
transplantate tätig da kommentiert wie
lange das sie wirklich reanimiert worden
ist pt sondern darüber klagt man über
dumme geschlagen und das raster schlüpft
ist in einem bogen autist swiss
transplantiert in kontakt mit den
spitälern das computersystem hat für
jedes organ eine reihenfolge der
patienten errechnet die zum zug kommen
könnten
jetzt hat auf der ersten position für
die leber und auch für die niere
rohstoffbasis durch die linke
aber wenn man sie ganz abgelehnt hätte
heute position
ich hatte auf position vier
das angebot läuft
drogen hier stürmt zum abladen von größe
gewicht ob das überhaupt wird besser
ob der empfänger überhaupt transplantat
ist aber gesund ist jetzt 20 punkten
wird transplantieren
das wissensportal ist auch der
altersunterschied zwischen spender und
empfänger sollte bei gewissen organen
nicht zu groß sein dachte stand ist das
wohnzimmer ist magic und weise von swiss
transplant er gibt die organe der
spender frei für die zuteilung ist in
erster linie entscheidend wie dringend
ein patient der spender organ braucht
das ist aber nicht immer eindeutig
algorithmus hin oder her wenn ihr beim
patiententag habe dringend ist und es
ist für die kolleginnen und kollegen
natürlich schwierig zu bestimmen also
kann da war wo das mittel aber von einem
tank an dieser stelle er letztendlich
eine landeszentrum zungen andere
dringende patient geht und dass sie
eigentlich sehr schwierige diskussionen
geführt und noch glücklicher wieso hört
meistens mit dem konsens unter deiner
der zentrum mehrerer seien aber dass sie
im moment wird in einem netzwerk gut
wurde nach immer wieder überlegt was ich
noch ein mini kolleginnen und kollegen
richtig entschieden
die abklärungen mit den empfänger
zentren können sechs bis acht stunden in
anspruch nehmen
in dieser zeit wird die verstorbenen
patientin weiter beatmet der kreislauf
stabilisiert der körper mit hormonen
versorgt die er nicht mehr selber bildet
die patientin wird gepflegt zu gunsten
der organempfänger
[Musik]
ist die organspende moralische pflicht
oder ist es verwerflich den körper zum
ersatzteillager zu machen
was soll nach dem tod geschehen
[Musik]
herzpatient bruno roman holt seinen sohn
ab der mit der mutter im nachbardorf
lebt seit vier jahren ist roman getrennt
der zehnjährige remy verbringt jedes
zweite wochenende beim vater
[Musik]
ihnen war
doch da man meinen
[Musik]
gemeinsam besuchen sie heute bonus
bruder an seinem arbeitsort eine
zimmerei in gstaad
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier nicht
euro
auch die nachwuchs kate nach der
operation silbernes zwei minuten jünger
als bruno sie sind einige
zwillingsbrüder beide sind gelernte
zimmerleute aber mit dem kunstherz kann
bruno nicht mehr arbeiten
was mach ich mich beschäftige tut
kollegen schaffen
als die brüder noch gemeinsam in diesem
betrieb arbeiteten einem silbern seinem
bruder die schwersten arbeiten ab beide
haben herzprobleme beide sind
unzertrennlich
das problem kommt
silvers herz hat sich erholt bei ms.de
transplantation kein thema mehr
und doch hat er das hobby
gleitschirmfliegen aufgegeben als bruno
aufhören musste
ohne ihn mache es keine freude mehr
[Musik]
marienberg direkt im laden
auch bei remy ist das interesse für das
gleitschirmfliegen geweckt
ich werde mit dem ferienpass
gleitschirmfliegen ein tandemflug wenn
inhalt und bricht andere sache
aber was sie habe ich werde schon mal
sagen ja das ist gut so sagt remy musste
sich damit abfinden dass vieles nicht
mehr gemacht haben
champignons im skifahren schon lange
alle hoffnung ruht auf der
bevorstehenden herztransplantation
operation was ich meinte hofbauer sich
nach mitternacht noch nie angst vor so
jetzt kann ich das gut
[Musik]
auf dem dach des schweizerischen kinder
lieber zentrums am unispital genf trifft
die leber für mirja 1
lea und ihre eltern werden nie erfahren
woher sie kommt der spender bleibt
anonym
für die empfänger könnte es belastend
sein details zu den todesumständen zu
erfahren
nur so viel ist klar es handelt sich um
einen teil einer erwachsenen liebe
[Musik]
doch seine verachtung die leber rutscht
bei jedem buch
die leber ist das einzige organ das sich
auf zwei empfänger aufteilen lässt
schöne momente im moment glücklich und
jetzt den langsamen spitzley der kontakt
mediziner ja und da man schnell machen
dass sie denn im schweizer team die
kranke leber wird erst jetzt heraus
geschnitten
wegen des seltenen gendefekt wird mir
als lieber genau untersucht werden
hier in genf aber auch im ausland die
forscher erhoffen sich aufschlüsse über
die krankheit
jetzt geht es darum die spenderleber mit
marias gefäßen zu verbinden
[Musik]
während die ärztin und ihr team in der
heiklen operation phase stecken wird das
warten für die eltern zur zerreißprobe
[Musik]
weil sich die frau
die größte anspannung scheint vorbei
barbara wildhaber spricht wie der
schweizer deutsch moment ganz unschuldig
ist und wo es denn so hoffe man so viel
tv mit der schönen rose lobt wird kann
ja schön wenn wir nicht statt
[Applaus]
nicht schön
dennoch hat er für die gute lage und den
wird sie ganz zufrieden sich aber
knallhart von den venen ein problem
haben ist jetzt sicher und wird sich so
vorteile produziert und alles was sie
müssen
[Musik]
kurz vor 19 uhr acht stunden nach beginn
der operation endlich die erlösende
botschaft
[Musik]
ich muss dich
bis die eltern die tochter wiedersehen
vergehen weitere zwei stunden
[Musik]
wenn sie so gemacht die fertig hier muss
der ladentür
[Musik]
die eltern wollen unbedingt deinem
ausgetragen
die waffenkammern öffnen muss ich doch
nun macht er braucht
[Musik]
kann er einen stuhl haben er hat mühe
die narbe zu sehen
dort ist
in der nächsten sendung nicola heiser
lebt seit fast zehn jahren mit einem
spenderherz alles wirklich gutes aber
ich sag jetzt mal so 98 vertrauen köpfe
die chirurgin vanessa bands ist
unterwegs zur organentnahme
und die reha kehrt zurück ins leben
[Musik]
ja